hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video seht
schon im titel eingeblendet ich habe ein
paar amazon artikel bestellen und die
sind alle relativ dummen also die wird
man sich jetzt als normaler mensch
glaube ich eher nicht bestellen das sind
fünf artikeln und von den fünf artikel
sind zwei sachen space mit einem geruch
das heißt die werde ich am ende
ausprobieren so bleibt auf jeden fall
dran wenn ihr sehen wollt wie ich
ersticke wir fangen an mit dem ersten
artikel muss wirklich sagen freunde
dieser artikel ist der verkaufsschlager
schlechthin jeder mensch will so etwas
irgendwann mal besitzen wurde es ist
einfach krass dass ich die möglichkeit
habe mir dies leisten zu können ich rede
hier von nichts geringerem als nichts
da ist wirklich nichts dritte bei amazon
einfach mal geguckt ob man sich
theoretisch nichts bestellen kann und da
steht wirklich drauf das geschenk für
alle die sich nicht wünschen absolut
nichts premium qualität
natürlich kaufen sich andere youtuber
immens teure klamotten oder irgendwelche
sportwaren prahlen damit in ihren videos
aber ich kaufe mir nichts wirklich trend
stellte das ganze ist einfach mal aus
ich hab's zerrissen
wir sind einfach sogar die inhaltsstoffe
drauf von diesem produkt namens nichts
und schaut euch das mal anders steht
über 10 gramm der moment der wahrheit
ist gekommen in der liebe freunde ich
werde diese box mund öffnen wenn da da
ich jetzt öffnen und die box stehen nach
plastik ist tatsächlich auch nichts
natürlich ist das ganze irgendwie dumm
sich nicht zugestellt aber man hat ja
immer irgendwie diese freund der sagt
hey ich wünsche mir nicht sondern
schenkt man die wir trotzdem die eine
flasche wein oder vielleicht irgendwie
süßigkeiten oder so oder irgendein
gutschein oder sowas und ich finde es
ist einfach mega es so man kann sagen
der etwas gesagt wünscht dir nichts hier
nichts ich mal das hat irgendwie acht
euro gekostet oder so die nächste sache
nicht mehr gestellt habe seien eine
halbe million euro
das sind nämlich laut der rückseite
beschädigte banknoten werden von der
deutschen bundesbank aus dem verkehr
gezogen und zerkleinern diese euro geld
machen wurden das original euro banknote
geschreddert das heißt das sind eine
halbe million euro allerdings der
shredder sieht das ganze aus also sind
quasi verschiedene geldnoten und die
sind alle irgendwie verkleinert worden
wenn ich das ganze auf reize seht ihr
schon dass es irgendwie nochmal
eingepackt ich weiß jetzt auch gar nicht
ob ich das ganze jetzt mal komplett
auspacken soll ich habe mir eigentlich
schon so eine schüssel geholt wo ich das
dann rein packe allerdings will ich das
ungern auf machen also das ist
eigentlich ein perfektes geschenk das
man irgendwann mal leben schenken kann
so von wegen jo ecker wir wissen uns
dass wir nichts gewünscht aber wir haben
eine halbe millionen euro für dich ist
doch fanny oder die nächste sache die
ich mir ebenfalls bestellt habe ist ein
golf cent fürs wc das seht ihr nämlich
schon da sitzt jemand auf dem klo und
hat nebenbei dieses golf set hier
aufgebaut wo er dann quasi beim
schweißen oder so golf spielen kann das
heißt ich denke dass jetzt mal nicht auf
dem klo war hier an meinem schreibtisch
also was in dem paket drin haben sind
schon mal zwei von diesen kleinen mini
golfbällen jesu golfschläger dem
unglaublich aufziehen kann und deshalb
billig qualität da noch dieses ging man
brauche ich den ball dann nachher ein
krieg um ja genau das ziel quasi und
noch dieser bodenbelag für den boden das
heißt wird das ganze jetzt mal einfach
auf dem brunnen lehrer sogar noch von
toiletten schildchen mit do not disturb
auf gamepro griffs mit dabei also diese
fahne muss auf jeden fall an das ziel
das die musiker hier aber ich habe noch
ein zweiter bayerischer freunde wie
platziere ich jetzt wieder genau hierhin
und versuche ich ich muss ja so tun als
ich auf dem klo sitzt der oberfläche für
die gamer kann
diesen ball geschossen was ihr bisher
quasi getestet haben ist dieses golf wcs
habe ich die favoriten geschlossen
werden dass golf wz getestet dann hab
ich euch die halbe million euro wie
zeige ich mir gekauft haben und die
verpackung wohl nichts drin war das
heißt die letzten beiden sachen jetzt
ins 2 ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht so
bock drauf übrigens wie dir wieder jedem
hintergrund dieser kisten eingeblendet
die gibt es nämlich wie schon im letzten
video gesagt ab dem 10 10 level genaue
uhrzeit litera werde ich kann ihnen
jedoch übers netz mit instagram twitter
kommunizieren zehnte streikrecht ist im
kalender
ich habe mich einmal ein pups spray
bestellt was halten voll nach 14 riecht
und einmal eine pizza salami pizza
raumspray was halt nach pizza salami
richten sollen
ich habe überhaupt keinen bock
eigentlich ziemlich einfach schuhe an
und wenn das dann nach draußen
herumstehen und stichwort zimmer nicht
danach das heißt während ich mir die
schuhe anziehen oder balkon oder flash
die moderation
sorry dass du manchmal fleisch ist
übrigens auch ein amazon artikeln
du bist aber kein dummer amazon artikel
gleich kommt aber aus frankreich das
heißt es ein bisschen wenn einer von
euch bock hat kann er eine fanpage ob
instagram für flash machen also
irgendwie flash oder keine ahnung was du
noch frei ist aber ich glaube er wird
sich freuen
okay ich bin jetzt gerade externer
ausgegangen dieses buchs prima als
erstes zu testen also wir klappen dass
man auch ich später mal so ein bisschen
von raus ohne spaß bestellt euch mal so
ein ding das ist was ist denn da drin
ich empfehle es niemanden sich dieses
buch spray zu kaufen ich spüre jetzt
noch mal hoch dass das ist nicht kurz
das ist verqualmte plastikmüll mit
gedärmen sache die wir jetzt testet
dieses pizza salami
das liegt schon noch pizza das ist
einfach viel zu stark genauso wie bei
diesem fußball vorhin das sind einfach
diese gerüche ist man könnte es erraten
dass es gut ist und dass hier pizza aber
es riecht einfach viel zu extra dieses
des nas brauchen mich jetzt mal ganz
weit aus dem fenster und sage dass ihr
sogar jeglicher ist als das push prey
also ohne spaß keine formalen reaktion
hier ist irgendwie getäuscht ich kann
auch so was schlecht faken andere
youtuber werde jetzt wahrscheinlich so
ich ausgerastet hätten seien kosten
vorgetäuscht oder so aber das ist echt
ey das ist bestellt euch das und riecht
daran dass kosten die zehn euro und das
buch ich habe schon ein bisschen
bauchschmerzen gerade also ich würde
nicht sagen dass es nach pizza salami
riecht sondern einfach nach dem
allgemeinen pizza also mit der geruch
ist ja gerade allgegenwärtig die ganze
zeit weil gerade gar kein wind hier am
start ist aha das ist einfach nur
ekelhaft ohne spaß ist ich habe meinen
bauch tut weh ich würde an dieser stelle
aber auch das video beende meine damen
und herren es war jetzt einfach ein paar
dumme amazon artikel die ich mir
bestellt hatte also zusammengefasst was
dieses klo golfspiel dann diese beiden
space hiernach halbe million euro eine
verpackung wohl nichts drin war wenn die
weitere idee da passen wir vielleicht
bei amazon bestellen könnte und mal
testen sollte für euch dann schreibt
vorne die kommentare last leichter wenn
es euch gefallen hat und die findet hier
einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf klickt könnte man kanal
abonnieren hier findet ihr ein video
eingeblendet wo ich schminke getestet
habe da habe ich ja auch ein bisschen
produkte getestet es vielleicht so
ähnlich witzig wie das hier
und dann
voll krass bei uns gerade fast 30 grad
ist ende september